So how do you heal the gut? You have to use specific nutrition. That's going to heal the gut.
You have to use prebiotics as well as probiotics. So most people they go, I got a bad gut.
So I'm going to take some probiotics and it just doesn't seem to make my gut better.
And understand this person right here with this gene defect might not have any quote-unquote gut symptoms.
So that's the beauty of looking at labs is that you bypass the person's symptomatology.
So they might not have any symptoms but they still have issues that we need to address.
This person with a gene defect like this, how would you treat it? They need to be on some gut nutrition.
They need to be on a prebiotic. They need to be educated on what prebiotics are in their normal diet.
And they need to be on a probiotic. Possibly doing probiotic animals, retention animals as well.
We need to heal their microbiota. So there's multiple avenues in this and we have a bunch of videos on this other website.
Because we're doing this with all our patients.
Any question over there first? Does that answer it? Perfect. Yes.
Can you get enough prebiotic fiber from your diet? Normally you can.
If you're eating good, you're eating some green bananas, you're eating some raw onion family foods,
you're eating some raw dandelion leaves, you're eating some chicory substances, things like that.
Those are all good prebiotics. If a person has a lot of FUT2G defects, I think they should supplement.
We use a product that I developed called Sun Spectrum. It has a modified guar gum that statistically from all the research is the best prebiotic of the market.
But again, a prebiotic is simply feeding, helping to feed those epithelial cells.
If you continue to have inflammatory processes going out of the gut, like you continue to eat poorly,
you continue to eat genetically modified foods and gluten all these inflammatory things,
even though they only don't cause any problems. They are. So it's a losing battle.
So you do have to make those changes as well. Yes. Is a fermented food prebiotic? No.
So fermented food has probiotics, but you're going to see it a little bit.
If you have specific gene defects, you're going to be very careful with those.
And if you're going to use a fermented food, fermented foods are a phenomenal source of probiotics.
I always tell my patients that just a couple of tablespoons of raw sauerkraut has more probiotics than your entire model of probiotics does.
However, you have to be careful with fermented foods because it contains a lot of histamine.
But if you have ABP1 gene defects that we're going to see in a second or HNMT gene defects, you can't use fermented foods.
Is that help? So this person needs some support of their gut. Still with me? Yes.
A flora is that the prebiotic? So the flora is the old term that's used that is now we call the microbiota.
So I don't know what you mean by flora. So they're probably, she said, you should use something for two weeks before starting your probiotics.
They're probably speaking of a prebiotic. That's probably what they were speaking of.
I think you can do it concurrently. I don't think there's a problem with that. So we put people out of product that uses it concurrently.
These are your ABP1 genes. The ABP1 genes that affect histamine.
So histamine is an inflammatory product that your body normally makes, but it's something that's a chemical that's in a lot of different foods as well.
The ABP1 genes are the genes that make the DAO enzyme that breaks down histamine in your gut and partly in your blood.
Very, very important gene because this tells us whether the person can use fermented foods. And by the way, side note, unfermented foods.
If you have a lot of leaky gut issues, you can't use fermented foods right away either because they'll cross the gut in larger molecules across the gut border and cause inflammation of the blood of the tissues.
So you've got to do some work on healing the gut many times not all the time before you can start using fermented foods.
So if a person has these gene defects and this person has double allele defect on one, I would be careful with this person using fermented foods.
So your ABP1 genes are really important. As a matter of fact, people with ABP1 gene defects and then this next family, this HNMT gene defects.
This can be the, this right here, the first part of the report, can be the main cause of the person's symptom problems right here.
So HNMT gene, these genes get rid of histamine in the tissue. Now again, you normally produce histamine. Histamine is an immune chemical that's produced in the presence of an antigen or an allergen in your body.
And it has a purpose, a very good purpose but it's supposed to have a very short half life. Why? Because the HNMT genes are making enzyme that break it down to get rid of it so that it's out of your body.
It does its job and it's out of your body. Now remember almost everything that we're going to talk about here, everything in your body is about balance.
It's all about balance. There's not necessarily good guys and bad guys, right? Bad guys are only bad guys when they're out of balance. The good guys can be bad guys when they're out of balance.
I'm going to take a bunch of antioxidants because I don't want any oxidation in my body. Well, then you're going to die of cancer.
Okay? You have to have some oxidants and free radicals in your body because that's what kills pathogens and cancer cells. But when you have too many, they can cause cancer.
Follow? It's all about balance. So just when, if I give a patient here, I want to take three of these a day and they go, well, I'm going to take 10 because that would be better because we're Americans.
That could be bad. So it's all about balance. Yes.
I'm just wondering if you're sure those variants there are another risk act tonight. How many more?
So good question. Do we know that these variants are truly problematic? Just by looking at the gene profile, we do not.
So there's other things that we could look at that I was going to put in the slide presentation too. But I thought, I don't want to bore you to death. I would literally kill you.
There's some other tests that we can run at organics tests that we can actually look at histamine levels. The only problem with those, the genetic test doesn't change.
The organic test changes rapidly because it's your current, a stepped photograph of your body chemistry that can be different right now compared to three hours from now.
So that's the only barrier to there.
I just one thought on I ran my 23 me through MTHR, MTHR.com and I thought, oh, I've got G6PD because I've got two double mutations.
I looked them up and they're just normal and I polymorphisms that need nothing. So I don't have G6PD and I did the quantitative test.
But I'm just wondering if you see these couple of things, you think, oh, it's bad, but it's just a normal polymorphism. Sure, you can do your O test and verify.
But I'm just wondering if you know for each of those genes that they are benign silence.
So we say what a person has G defects, does that mean they're doomed? Does that mean that's causing a symptom pattern in their body?
I'm more asking, let's say you take the time line and if there's a defect in there, could it be that that doesn't affect the H and MTH anyway?
Okay, so with our 20 seconds we have left. Remember one thing, that defect in that gene does not mean that that gene is not working completely.
And we don't even know that that, just because there's research on the MTHFR, 677 gene, and we'll talk about later that a double allele defect decreases its function by 65%. That's on average.
And even at that it's still working. So it doesn't mean you're doomed to that disease or you're doomed to a problem with that.
It just means that we do have compromise in there, especially with the greater amount of defects in a family.
That's all we can really say. And so the environment trumps everything. So if your environment is good, then you're going to have less problems with that gene profile.
Now again, if a person's coming to me typically they have symptoms. So then we want to clarify their genetics with their symptoms and really get a better picture on what we want to support.
Does that help? So there's no guarantee that just because I have defects that I'm going to absolutely have problems, but there's also no guarantee if I have zero defects that I'm not going to have a whole host of problems.
Because I, just because I don't, let's say this person is actually really, really good actually in their H&MT, but I have had people with single and double allele defects almost every one of those.
The chance of that person having histamine clearing problems is like through the roof.
Does that make sense? So you want to address it.